so as you know the Nobel week dialogue
is mainly about discussion now I'm very
pleased to have the chance to have a
short discussion with the 2006 recipient
of the Nobel Peace Prize Muhammad Yunus
about this issue these issues of poverty
food and malnutrition so Muhammad Yunus
thank you very much so first let me ask
you is poverty inevitable oh not at all
why should any human being be suffering
from this humiliation and also
condemnation and such a state of affairs
that for no fault of his or her own is
something poverty is not something
coming from the poor people it's not
self created phenomenon it's an
externally imposed phenomenal so if it's
externally imposed phenomenon so we can
remove that and let people come out it's
a it's something you put a person in a
sort of a prison can't take any action
on his or her own and that's what the
poverty is all about so it's a Fault in
the system that we developed ourselves
the institutions that we created
policies that P pursue so if you say
okay probably ignore poverty that means
you don't want to go back and look look
around what you have done to the
billions of people on this planet and
where should the solution come from is
it from change the system change the
system basically all the things Chris
Gamble one of the work that we got
involved with is bringing financial
services to the poor people why did we
have to do that why don't the financial
institution themselves create in a way
so that it's available to everybody
nobody's denied all the arguments that
were giving us right from the beginning
when we are struggling to draw their
attention that your system is wrong they
said we don't do it because people are
not credit worthy and I first try to
understand what does it mean people are
not credit worthy then I realized that
what away they have extracted from
themselves from this whole
responsibility I said
should banks decide the people whether
people are creditworthy or not but
should it be raised in a different way
whether people should decide whether the
banks are people were there loud so this
this is how you have to it the questions
are raised in a way so that it protects
you then we went down and we offered our
financial services and it worked you
were saying it won't work why why you
take the trouble of doing that so we
started lending money and people are
paying back then they said maybe it's a
strange phenomenon in one country if you
do it in a bigger way in other countries
this will not work because this is very
funny you lend money to poor people and
they're paying back you expect us to
believe that and we say pardon should
come and check it out and they did in
many ways and they say well maybe it's a
funny thing in Bangladesh but you cannot
work out elsewhere but it worked ever
now we are invited in the United States
saying that it may work in other
countries but the United States very
different it will not work here I said
what should work anywhere because we are
dealing with the people not with the
country so people need it and you
provide it and they change their life so
they invited us to start a program to in
2008 we call they become in America and
started in jackson height in New York
City in Queens we had no idea whether
it's in to work but our firm belief that
it should work because it works in any
other situation so what we did we send
one of our managers in bangladesh in in
the village who runs branches there ask
him to do in the united states he came
and he set it up I told him that forget
about what you see in the United States
your job is not to worry about United
just do the work that you do in
Bangladesh exactly the same way in
precisely he did it and it worked now we
have 19 branches all over the United
States with 18,000 85,000 borrowers it's
all about 11 cities in Jackson in Los
Angeles San Francisco maha brass can buy
the other cities and it works perfectly
it really is 99.5
it's all about the individual isn't it
it's about individual is about human
beings human beings are willing waiting
for opening opportunities they have the
talent they're full of creative capacity
each human being has unlimited creative
capacity but we created the system which
kind of pushes it down the other than
now help you to bring it out poverty is
some kind of a barrier that you put
around them so that they cannot export
themselves who you are what you are
capable of so you opened it up suddenly
they expose all kinds of possibilities
inside of them and their children take
it up and make it further than make it
further expansion of their capacity tell
me a little about the network's you've
set up in Bangladesh to help relieve the
problem of child malnutrition your
collaboration with Dan own it shows it's
an example of a big business taking on
the the challenge of social business you
know when we're doing again their
lending and financial institution that
argument that were making see the gold
Grameen Bank was born in the context of
famine people dying of hunger because
this no food for them so when you talk
about family and suddenly your attention
is drawn to the food every history of
famine it placed within the region that
we are from it's not about food food was
there but reasonable amount of food is
available simply people could not go and
get it because they don't have the
purchasing power so is the income so I
keep saying that the most important
thing in food is income if you are
looking at the feeding people and so on
so that people can feed themselves so
this is number one responsibility how to
make that income possible for everybody
so that they can claim their share in
the food that they can first guess the
first thing and then we saw that not
only food is important the quality of
food is important simply volume of food
is important but quality of the food is
also important more important than food
itself that we see after all this we
have done in Bangladesh reaching are so
many families around the country but
it's still there's a problem
of meditation for the eight percent of
the children of bangladesh and managed
so what kind of nation you build with
malaria children with the stunted growth
with stunted mental faculty and so on so
we thought we should do something an
opportunity came because daniel was very
interested in what we do a social
business and we created a series of
social businesses these are businesses
again I was talking about the changing
the system the system says the whole
business should be based on personal
interest you should be maximizing the
benefit from business yourself I said
that's the wrong interpretation of the
human being human beings are not robots
to make themselves enriched by doing
things as a human being is a
multi-dimensional being not
one-dimensional being is selfish at the
same time surface the selfless past was
never included in the business so we
created series of businesses which fits
into that category business to solve
problem rather than make money for
themselves that's what we call social
business non-dividend company to solve
human problems and we created lot in
somehow done all got interested in the
subjects because I speak about it I
wrote books about it they wanted to meet
me and discuss this so we met and out of
that came a creation of a social
business in Bangladesh a joint venture
Grameen and general addressing the
malnutrition of the children this is
social business which produces a special
kind of yogurt put all the
micronutrients which are missing in the
children but I mean I don't say impaired
in etc make it very cheap make it very
delicious so that poor children are
attracted to it and can pay for it and
it became a successful business people
at which children are eating their
overcoming their malnutrition they are
getting back their micronutrients it is
a social business because danone doesn't
want to make money out of it they see it
as a social business you can take back
the investment money but nothing beyond
there ok thing is done to help solve the
problem good and that's been a wonderful
taster for further discussion of social
business the idea of business not being
just for prof
but for problem solving absolutely we'll
talk about it later in the day but I of
all people mustn't go over time so may I
thank you very much indeed this taster
[Applause]